Mẹ ơi. Mẹ đã Vượt Biên để Con Có Thể Bay Cao Mẹ Vượt đại.
Dương để Hôm Nay Con Chậm Cả Bầu Trời.
That heritage inspired me to study the stars at Harvard and NASA.
But I was raped
and found out that the government would destroy my evidence.
At the crossroads of justice or my astronaut dreams,
I chose justice.
For 10 years,
I traded my telescope for a pen to draft laws protecting survivors.
Congress in the UN passed my legislation unanimously,
impacting 1.3 billion people across the world.
When I started my activism,
I made a promise to myself.
One day I would return.
I didn't need to sacrifice who I am to do good
to the girl who has waited your life for this day.
The girl I was before I was hurt
and carried the hurt of millions of others.
I honour my promise to you.
We make it through.
Your dreams matter.
They come true.